une grande fierté et une grande émotion
que de présider le groupe qui est au
coeur de la majorité présidentielle et
au coeur évidemment de l'action des
nationales dans un moment politique dans
un moment institutionnalisé qui quand
même assez inédit logés on n'est plus
majoritaire sol et ne plus être
majoritaire seul ça impose aussi de
changer nos méthodes de travail pour des
raisons évidentes on a toujours été dans
la discussion dans le dialogue
évidemment même quand nous étions dans
une majorité absolue mais là c'est un
impératif parce que si on ajoute les
textes qui sont clés pour l'avenir des
français puissent être adoptées à nous
on a la responsabilité d'aller chercher
du compromis mais il ya aussi un moment
de vérité pour les autres groupes
politiques de l'opposition pour savoir
si clairement leur ans solange de sept
blocs et willard en jeu ce motif se
payer un tel brevet ont chacune ensemble
depuis 2007 et depuis la campagne
présidentielle
manu est donc c'est déjà aussi quelque
chose qui humainement est très fort et
puis c'est un final je trouve qui est
extrêmement positif de se dire qu'on a
deux femmes qui pour la première fois en
plus de l'histoire de l'assemblée
nationale moi déjà élu président du
groupe majoritaire ça n'était jamais
arrivé
natra semblait mardi jugeant que nous
aurons la confirmation de l'élection au
perchoir comme on dit donc à la
présidence de la semaine est celle de
yale gros deux pilotes je crois que
c'est ça fait du bien au dessus de
montrer que vous permet notre majorité
je peux renouvellement
fille de comédiens son père alain dorval
et notamment la voix française de
sylvester stallone aurore bergé après
des études à sciences po et le passage
par la publicité s'oriente très tôt vers
la politique d'abord membre de l'ump
puis des républicains et les
responsables des jeunesses populaires
des yvelines en 2014 elle est candidate
à la mairie de magny les hameaux mais
des fêtes par le maire sortant bertrand
ou lyon elle ne sera que conseillère
municipale d'opposition en 2016 elle se
tient alain juppé candidat à l'élection
présidentielle et après la défaite de
l'ancien premier ministre face à
françois fillon elle rejoint l'équipe de
campagne d'emmanuel macro élu député de
la 10e circonscription des yvelines en
2017 elle devient porte-parole du groupe
parlementaire puis du mouvement lrm on
cite son nom comme probables secrétaire
d'état à la communication de le premier
gouvernement castex elle ne sera
finalement pas nommé en septembre 2020
et les candidats déjà à la présidence du
groupe à l'om contre l'ancien ministre
de l'intérieur christophe castaner
finalement d'élus après un deuxième tour
serré christophe castaner la nommera
présidente déléguée du groupe membre de
la commission des affaires culturelles
s'est beaucoup intéressé lors de son
premier mandat ou questions touchant à
la communication à l'éthique notamment à
la pma à la culture et au sort des
artistes confrontés à la crise sanitaire
et à la protection animale largement
réélu dimanche dernier avec plus de 63%
des suffrages elle est la deuxième femme
présidente d'un groupe parlementaire
dans l'histoire de la république après
valérie rabault qui présidait le groupe
socialiste mais elle est la première
femme à diriger un groupe majoritaire